alexis staff alain fauquet écoles pour
qu'elle vit normalement m'organiser
c'est une garantie à l'automne sur ton
nouveau chantier donnez moi un peu de
temps pour remonter le chenal de la
liste ensemble
maxime leflaguais c'est reparti pour la
troisième saison de l'émission les pays
d'en haut où tu incarnes alexis la
branche un jeune amoureuse tourmentée
pense le public québécois m'a découvert
basse dans ce rôle là même ça faisait 12
13 ans j'ai roulé ma bosse d'histoire
hall qui ai beaucoup aimé
je me rends compte quand c'est
l'amoureux comme tu dis qu'est qui est
tourmenté qui que des bonnes valeurs je
pense les québécois sur la cohérence
personnage là mais quand je vais quand
je me promène dans le pays dans la
province fait beaucoup parler rugby plus
apte à jouer dans le film
guy provost dans la série originale des
grands souliers à chausser ça pour toi
oui vraiment rude vie c'est gros c'est
très droit chaussée puis je même que des
fois je jouais puis je me disais non je
t'en prendre la voie des défenses prince
je me disais merde jeudi puis vendredi
puis là je tendrais le métamorphoser en
lui même non non je me recentre à ce
moment là puis je redevenais moi même
surtout dans les pays d'en haut mais
également dans le film piché entre ciel
et terre
donc je pense qu en surjouant ce film là
si réalisé par sylvain archambault qui
était visé par certaines allégations
d'inconduite sexuelle toi comment tu
aurais réagi ben j'ai réagi c'est un ami
sylvain avant tout donc ce que je trouve
bien dans ce rôle là c'est que les gens
qui avaient des choses à dire on dit ce
qu'elle a dit dont ils ont dénoncé
certains comportements et sylvain ont
répondu donc si verdi luys comment il
vivait seul
donc je pense qu'à partir de ce moment
là
moi j'ai pas des pionners justement là
très soulagé parce qu'on a vu une vidéo
où avec caroline dhavernas vous montrer
votre soutien à la catalogne
ouais comment fait ses choix de dire
chemin des styles en telle cause et je
n'embarque pas dans telle autre cause
une bonne question je pense faut suivre
notre car c'est une cause qui nous parle
moi je suis porte parole pour la cause
de la trisomie 21 mais j'ai perçu
connais personne que la trisomie 21 dans
mon entourage mais c'est un ami qui m'a
demandé ça puis je me suis dit pourquoi
pas je dois y est tellement de cause je
pense honnêtement toutes les causes sont
bonnes puisque moi si je pouvais je les
ferai tout mais on est en manque de
temps je suis pas en faveur pour le
cancer testiculaire aussi la catalogue
ça me parlait jeu s'ouvre et laisse donc
je trouvais ça important de compte que
les gens comprennent que quand la
démocratie bafouée jeu c'est grave ce
qui s'est passé en capable de les taper
sur le monde qui va voter je trouvais ça
vraiment horrible pressentant
[Musique]
toi
mais il ya aussi la musique c'est une
deuxième carrière
à terme la musique j'ai toujours écrit
de la poésie en fait depuis que ce tout
jeune j'ai gagné quelques plus poésie
quand j'étais ado j'étais tellement
chanceuse que quand j'ai écrit deux
récentes en deyris
et sa gérante et emmanuelle girard ont
approché louis-jean il aux gens d'être
des gens quand je la vois de burris
avait dit j'aimerais c'est à collaborer
avec toi et finalement à lui envoyer mon
texte
c'est ce qu'on doit chanter moi je suis
un fan de louis jean depuis vingt et un
de ses tout débuts de karkwa
donc je teste en honneur pour moi
vraiment très chanceux que son timing
comme on dit que tu
ce que je sais
[Musique]
un cadre et son troupeau
j'ai envoyé une chanson de l'année à
montréal moffatt j'en vois deux des
chansons un peu à gauche à droite mais
je serai sans dilettante donc j'ai pas
trop de pression je cache inspiré
j'écris ça m'aide quand j'ai la mélodie
d'abord quand j'ai la mélodie samed ça
m'inspire vraiment à trouver des mots
telle arme pour mon bain des larmes
couteau cinéaste vie tiroirs miroir
parce que parfois sans une certaine
pression sur les épaules
entre autres parce que ce fils de
véronique le flaguais une choucroute
non je sens pas de pression j'ai j'ai la
chance c'était la chance n'est pas
d'avoir des parents connus la chance
d'avoir des parents connus et aimés du
milieu donc moins si mes parents je sais
qu'ils ont une bonne réputation dans le
milieu ils m'ont quand j'arrive sur un
plateau légende je travaille mes parents
me disaient tu travailles avec michel
j'ai travaillé une chaise j'ai travaillé
véronique sud et ses allures de
m'apporter embrasse peuple c'est
toujours ça c'est toujours beaucoup
d'amour là quant à eux sur un plateau
champel pression change et de l'amour
qui que je dois ensuite le transférer à
mes parents car je les vois c'est pas
c'est pas c'est pas trés lot célé j'ai
l'amour maintenant la suite pour toi
c'est quoi
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qui m'attendait
plus de perdre si j'espère pige puis la
comédie à la maison engagée non pas la
comédie j'aimerais sauf à la comédie
c'est si rare ya plus de projets et des
projets web ce mais j'arrête h avoir une
entrevue je le dis je veux faire la
comédie puis un jour ça va pas nier que
c'est maxime faguer